hello welcome to Broken through broken
through that screen right now
so broken through is probably about the
horrors of going on the internet
um and living life connected to everyone
through a web of information
Ava Williams son Leo Williams went
missing countless investigations and
countless searches took place but no
glimpse of where he went seven years
after this incident Ava Williams got a
letter saying that Leo Williams was
declared legally dead since they never
found any evidence as to where he went
or where he is now
I'm not sure that's how they do that
when people go missing but what do I
really know I've never gone missing
that you know of
hi oh my goodness well that should be
everything
okay thank you for stopping by
I know Leo would have wanted you to have
some of his stuff knowing how close you
two were
but anyways I guess I'll be heading back
inside
drive safe okay
all right take care
bye-bye
bye bye let's get all these boxes onto
the truck
okay
Wham add box
only one at a time I'm not that strong
that box
nothing weird about this
get in the car it's a truck
hmm
one of the few people in all of America
using the truck for its intended purpose
broken
[Music]
am I about to be broken
oh I think I might be about to be broken
[Music]
I think I think I might be getting into
an accident in my breakthrough
or not no I'm I'm dead I'm dead I'm a
dead man I'm a dead man do I want to
control the vehicle should I control the
vehicle I'm feeling the midnight
Munchies that's not a good feeling
that's probably terrible I'll stop by 11
7 and get a bag of chips before driving
home yeah I'm dead I'm a dead man I'm
dead I'm freaking dead I'm dead
Undead
you know for some people driving out
late at night is going to be a very
peaceful experience I do like that in
fact I went out for a run just last
night but the way I run is probably
different than how most people run I use
Zombies Run the app I turn on as many
chases as possible I play music that is
exclusively almost all Nightmare Horror
Scapes Ambiance things that could give
you lots of waking nightmares and I try
to make it as horrific and experience as
possible and it also just so happens
that I'm running in an area full of uh
with cougars and coyotes and there have
been some bear sightings so I try to amp
up the danger factor which causes me to
run a little faster you know I used to
hate running but given all the things
that I do to try to make it as
terrifying and scarring appearance and
experience is possible it kind of is fun
I'm not a Mascus I know this sounds like
I'm trying to put myself in danger and I
like the thrill of the the risk of it
all but that's not exactly what it is I
just find it more entertaining for the
Zombies Run experience science to be
able to amp up the idea of in paranoia
that there might actually be zombies all
around me
did I mention I do this in pitch black
at night where there's no Street lamps
there's got to be other people that do
this too that has to be a thing that
other people do as well right okay you
got chips get some snacks what lovely
lips you have
I am literally me explaining that
running story is me showcasing that I am
a horror game protagonist who is bound
to die
at a moment's notice lazy's tips Doritos
cool stank well you know ordinarily I'd
go cool ranch but I just like plain old
potato chips oh
God damn it I didn't even see those
whatever I'll take these thank you
I'll get more than oh green beans can I
get some green beans
oh my God
it's romantic green beans and grilled
giant corn good extend that's grief
it's literally you don't want a green
ninja
turtles yeah
sorry
that's deep lore but not that deep some
of you may know why that bothers me some
of you might realize that that is
probably an intentional choice that they
made to irk with me specifically and if
it's not then my ego is getting away
from me
covered in ketchup oh no
oh that's not ketchup is it well um
spicy noodles I I don't know what else
to do can I oh
hey I'm just getting these chips
all right let's see here that'll be two
bucks but hold it you really want to buy
that bag of chips it barely has any
chips just air uh yeah maybe I could
interest you in buying my own brand that
I'm working on Jordan's Jolly jipper
Hall zero air 100 chip I even made a
commercial for it uh I don't think that
I'm I mean
I'm kind of sold
do you want to see the commercial maybe
it'll change your mind yeah actually yes
oh
hi my name is Jordan I'm a question are
you
foreign
is
that was the best commercial I've ever
seen of inspired at some point in this
video I will make a commercial just like
that to promote something of my own
thank you for the inspiration Jordan
what the [ __ ] please buy it yeah but
what do you mean it was a great
commercial all right thank you I'll give
it to you for a dollar special friend
price how did you say that out loud how
did you say this but anyways three
dollars for two bags of chips choose my
payment amount
take a tip pal there you go I knew I was
a good businessman yeah that you are
anyway have a good day bye
bye I guess I've got chips
I've got Jordan jorbo's jellies
okay I'm gonna head home now
crash into anything
well on the road again going home that's
fine I wonder if I've got a favorite
commercial on the radio I hope there's
something good to play here
hi
hi here to tell you all about the
wondrous world of distractible
distractible is a show on the radio but
not
but not as radio waves to broadcast
information to your location wherever
you go
on radio
on the internet
radio the internet is a series of tubes
the content you deserve through
extractable is available only
exclusively in this location Down Below
in the description I'm going to pull the
description up to show you that it's
actually down there
it's back now you can click on it anyway
if you go to the link in the description
below right now you too can partake in
Wonders that is distractible and enjoy
and Wade
Mark
who's me and the fun times we share in
this wonderful show what did we make
this for you
available will be discounted price of
100 off
you can take 100 off of zero which is an
ordinary cost to list
wow that was the perfect amount of time
for me to get home what an informative
commercial it really suited my needs I'm
getting out now okay I've got some
my stuff
well that kid's stuff
I guess I got it that's all I needed to
hear mine now in my house somehow based
on a recurring childhood nightmare
oh I forgot I barely even started this
game I went on a lot of tensions there
and I I may not be exactly what I meant
to do
[Music]
eating
so hard
that's enough TV for tonight I agree can
I eat more chips no okay all right well
um weird empty room with no windows
[Music]
all right goodbye I guess I'm gonna go
well I might as well open the boxes
before heading to bed
I know where the boxes are but okay
better turn out all the lights did I
turn out the lights in there I better
turn out the lights I don't want to be a
power waster
oh I can't I can't oh
apparently
no
just gotta I'm not a power waster
there we go okay good
it's dark in here
oh good oh a bunch of books
useless [ __ ]
ugly clothes man that dead kid had no
taste oh a game I should give it a try
on my computer
should I
uh posters fine
well hope no demons are staring at me
right now
yeah it's time to go game
okay I'm gonna go play a video game that
I found in a dead Kid's Stuff newly made
bed yeah good good hello God oh God I
would never keep my windows open at
night oh never never who could do that
what kind of psychopath keeps their
windows open at night you insert game
okay whatever you say whatever you say
pal
whatever you say ooh use Arrow Keystone
Navigator select interact okay
fourth world credits 1989.
what a coincidental year Tom Thomas
that's it okay
[Music]
all right
[Music]
why do I feel like something's gonna
appear in the window over there
also is it just me or is this game quiet
obviously it won't be to you because
lexian will have boosted it to the
proper level that you can hear it
properly
hello you have a choice
why is your body uh
okay
I have a choice or you have a choice
and what the choice is
you know those woods look a lot like the
woods outside my house
oh no no oh no
hi
don't continue down this
path
I don't know if I should listen to the
dude with long long arms so I won't not
gonna do that
oh
Martha's sound
oh rumbling
big rumbling
oh boy
I have a feeling I'm gonna come up
I don't feel like that man God I don't
like that good dude all right not
interacting with you I know not to talk
to strangers I'll see you around never
no I won't Whatever
[Music]
beware of a man in the coat
is that you some tells me I should be
aware of you good freaking God okay
don't uncomfy I don't like that open
window what demon keeps their blinds
open at night any of you are you so
weird that you do such a terrible thing
oh good God
oh
wait I'm gonna zoom in on that is that a
coat you have a coat I've been taught to
beware of you
[Music]
oh hi what lovely coat you have
oh hey don't no stop hey stop that stop
don't do it all right oh
he has broken through ah
interesting
get up why would I
couldn't possibly be my house
[Applause]
all right I'll exit
light switch it's not working
good thing I turned off all my lights
and conserve my power then he'll never
think anyone's home
uh oh
oh no
oh
boy
oh
I oh
I don't think things should be floating
in the air the game has just begun good
that's great wouldn't want people to
think that it was over already you're
here for entertainment value aren't you
aren't you lovely people
finish four of his levels or undergo a
fate worse than death is this what
happened to the kid
I think this is what happened to the
other kid good thing I'm a skilled Pro
Gamer with a thousand hours of fortnite
under my belt and thousands of hours of
Roblox
I'm an expert to finish a level locate
the door
easy
I've been looking at doors all my life
you think I'm gonna be you think I'm
gonna be missing out on a door this is
gonna be easy
there's gonna be sleazy
Beware of the entities
is that what I just heard roaring is in
and one of them entities
oh but I don't know I don't like that
all right okay all right good one
I'm going
I'm I'm going I went
I'm here now hello hi
what a lovely game
as I crossed the bridge I had tears in
my eyes and I simply imagined myself
diving into the water and drowning
myself
Tom Thomas Michael Scott all right good
whatever that means I don't want to
drown
I don't want to dive into any River I
don't have that urge people say that
they have intrusive thoughts and usually
you know you can keep those under
control I just never had the intrusive
thought in the first place
I don't want to jump off a bridge when
I'm standing on the edge I don't want to
throw my phone level one the bridge
well I just need to find the door right
and beware the entities
so if I'm not mistaken probably the
doors
some place here that I gotta jump off
here's Splish Splash
Splish Splash
plastic
[Music]
oh there's a boat
hello
shut up shut shut the [ __ ] up shut it up
shut up shut up
pass with care
I feel like this is a clue
keep to the right getting guy drunk
look through what do I well should I
would I all right
[Music]
oh well that is a sight for sore eyes
I'm not sure why that's there
but okay
[Music]
oh no ketchup
am I supposed to find a door here
because I thought I'd be really good at
the door finding thing usually a door on
a bridge wouldn't be too much of a
challenge but it seems like this place
is lacking a lot
don't even freaking think about it
don't even freaking think about it
oh
who's stomping
who's stomping
don't stop
don't you dare oh my God don't get
brighter
don't do that
me the birming my glowing balls oh
um
okay
[Music]
probably fine probably fine hello Hi how
are you good great wool
but that is oh hi oh tree tree that
again no doors I thought
that was a good idea all right fine hey
he got no run no lead up no lead up
whatsoever really no lead up you're not
gonna lead up you don't lead up you
wouldn't take a few steps back
man it was a bold risk
fine whatever maybe I'm the crazy one
maybe any of you
not me you know strangely enough not me
I don't think I would have done oh good
there's really oh it's ground I thought
it was water hello door
[Music]
door
door
I found the door
did I do it
I did it I'm the greatest
okay
I guess I did I didn't even see an
entity there easy peasy I thought it was
gonna be a challenge I could just blaze
through this then no problem hello
what is it what do you want
sometimes I wish I could just close my
eyes and then be in a better place when
I open them again
Tom Thomas okay great
do I have to close my oh my God oh God
I'm gonna have to close my eyes
oh I'm gonna have to not look at things
maybe this is actually that thing where
I do have to look at things button
no God oh it's awfully colorful
not sure what I'm supposed to be doing
oh do I gotta memorize or something oh
God do I I can't I couldn't possibly I
don't know if there's puzzles or things
I actually have to run away from oh it
is oh crap
all right is there anyone lurking in
here all right okay
so we got green
one green one green two green two green
okay I don't even know the order of the
the numbers okay so it's green is the
second red green blue yellow red green
is cool so dodo blue one two
three
okay three red green blue
red you're not gonna trick me that's one
of the buttons one two
one of the circles three
four
trying a new system of memorizing yellow
I only see one
yellow is one so
all right that's foolproof memorization
Toto
is that actually three is the button not
one of them I thought it was very clever
all right my dumb
I thought it was clever with that is
there another yellow or something blue
one two
three
four there's four blues okay
oh oh the button didn't count as one oh
that was just oh God
scp-087ba interesting
okay what is this
close them immediately when you see him
then close them close them my eyes
oh okay oh boy this is not good oh boy I
don't know what he looks like so if I
see him what do I do I don't like it I
don't like it I don't like it oh god
look [ __ ] yeah Frick here I'm gonna like
it fool where is he where are you show
yourself don't do it but don't maybe
stop yourself from doing it
don't show you anything to me
you're nothing it's a trash bin shut up
don't show yourself I'll never see it
stop go
but don't
be careful with what you wish for when
you don't do anything
all right fine he's not coming out
just gonna I'm just gonna he might not
have been there but I'm just gonna
there oh
well that's not good I don't see anybody
I'm not panicking I'm never panicked I
know exactly what I'm doing and how I'm
doing it
when I see him and I think I'll know
when I see him I'm closing my eyes
in the blink of an eye
specifically this one mine right now
here oh God stop go what
was that him
I don't think that was him that wasn't
him
turns out that wasn't him
she's a missing person oh
don't look look don't
all right is that who I'm looking for or
is it someone else am I gonna know when
I see him
oh
that sounded like it was behind me oh my
God I hate everything about this I hate
everything oh God
oh
[Music]
hey there he was
that was the one I didn't even get a
good look at him I wasn't even looking
at him because that's what I was
supposed to do not look at him what was
that stop don't be anything what in the
world was that I hated that but I beat
it I could kick your ass if you could
lose to a closing of the ice and are you
that tough in the first place shut up
well missing person ah interesting was
that the face of the person that was
there was that what happened
I feel like that was what happened
hopefully I don't double click when he
comes back around again could be any
minute now
is he in that trash can
oh frick I just got a notification but
it's fine keep my beepers peeled and
focused in ah where are you brick
frick frick my hair is getting in my
eyes
it's bothersome
oh hey oh
foreign
what do you mean
what what don't stop don't get in here
you don't want any of this dude
let's stop
don't do it this is a Huggy wuggy level
oh my God stop stop don't do it you no
don't I see you in there hold on right
no my lust I might but no the Temptation
stop
I don't want any of you you
stop who did it you cloth is slow I'm
not even worried about you ride
stop the way you moan is not cool
oh God stop stop don't do it stop don't
laugh at me
stop stop stop stop you thought you
wrong what the frick is Jack what the
frick is it it's a door dude it's good
freaking out of here freak
almost lost my cool there
almost too easy all right
what next
to almost too easy we got four of these
things easy
uh anyway
what's uh going on here what do you got
come on shut up give me a challenge
when me and my wife got divorced I could
still feel myself crawling after her
and the Darkness Crawling After me
well that's cool and all my microphones
are kind of bored at the moment there we
go one
okay so I'm gonna have to crawl is that
is that what I'm getting at yeah my
microphone was basically facing
backwards that's that's not good for
anybody involved
um but I'm gonna have to crawl after who
and why and what
and where
oh freaking event it's
just with markiplier all over again
when's the last time you watched that
have you visited Yancey in a while why
don't you go watch it again don't know
what I'm talking about go check out a
high school Markiplier but not now later
and then the space with Markiplier why
not I'm very proud of it a lot of people
worked at level three what what the
vents
well that seems obvious now
so um
what's the um the deal
left is best left left and left left oh
frick divorce agreement oh God no don't
make me look at this
God the terror the horror
well so long as I don't pick too many
wrong answers I think I'll be okay
unless every path leads to divorce good
thing Tom Thomas is just as a beacon of
sunshine and rainbows and happiness
or else this would be a depressing
experience
left is best
easy
[Music]
always knew it
oh that's not good oh frick oh bro my
God I want to look behind me so badly oh
God I wish I could see by me I'm gonna
look I'm gonna look I'm not looking
anymore I would never look why would I
look oh Rick don't look at me I want to
look oh God what's behind me oh God
Elixir and put up some AI generated
images of what could possibly be behind
me I'm looking I'm looking I shouldn't
look there was nothing there it's always
in my mind
oh he was never there to begin with oh
yeah I want to look oh God I want to
look so badly
oh frick I wanna look so bad oh God
slow good thing I'm fast oh man I am so
far ahead I could I could never look I
would never look gone
like I wanna look I'm gonna look
I see nothing there was nothing it's all
a figment of my imagination
it could be nothing it's never anything
I'm looking again whoa it's something
there oh left his rest left this one no
don't do this to me
oh frick I'm fine I don't even know what
it looks like how could I be afraid of
it it's just my mind playing tricks on
me
ah well let's try that again
maybe I shouldn't look behind me fast
forward back to where I was
how was your day
you having a good day
great good to hear
I've been busy doing stuff
ings and having an overall really fun
cool time okay there's nothing over
there right is it dead end okay same as
usual
all right and wouldn't you know it uh
later I'm gonna go get some food uh and
I'm gonna get a snack I got an air fryer
recently and it's really convenient to
be able to cook things so I'm gonna do
exactly that all right uh never do oh
man I never do anything to oh good
that's good
you
know
ah
good
[Music]
did I make it oh good I made it oh good
oh good
only one more that was easy what do you
do you think I'm a baby I think I'm just
like a gaming baby I'm a gaming God I've
been playing games for longer than you
have been missing
so that's your fault I'm done I finished
the game and now I feel much better
I feel like a different person the man
in the code well all you did was spread
your curse you freak you loser not you
that guy the man the code I got a good
feeling about this next one now I saved
the easiest for last
State you said before level four fourth
world
foreign
nothing
all right then so this looks a lot like
the intro when I was walking through the
woods and I saw at my window and I'm
sure that there was something scary
looking at me but I didn't see it
so what does this have to do with
everything here
what do I need to do
oh hi
how are you doing what's up
we are all as human As You Are
you're our only hope to save us all Tom
Thomas has been corrupted by The Entity
including his game
The Entity transformed his creation into
an endless loop in which Tom Thomas
relives his darkest times in life over
and over again through each level The
Entity feeds off torturing the innocent
by luring people into this corrupted
game
but if you bring Tom Thomas back you
bring all of us back
okay
um
inspect orb
hi Tom
[Music]
Barney gray missing since then okay good
how do I hello is that was that are you
the same person or you all right goodbye
oh boy another orb
oh
oh Carlos boo blessing buying a game
[Music]
it's almost like they all tried to warn
me and yet my own hubris got in the way
have you heard that story before
these are some nice orbs oh
no
last scene in his bedroom
ah
good great I welcome the little bit of
analog horror flavor into this all big
orb that's a nice one
Leo
Leo Williams last scene playing a game
by a lake well that was his first
problem playing a game by a lake if you
find a haunted arcade cabinet that
emerged mysteriously from the lake don't
play it it's not like King Arthur you
ain't gonna be king England you ain't
gonna be king of nothing
hello
many people have gone missing have
actually just ended up here do you know
anything about Leo Williams nice he is
the one who has gotten the farthest in
the game out of us all
are you too close by any chance
he was my best friend he went missing
seven years ago and we all thought he
was dead by now
on that case I could help you catch up
to him there's a glitch in this map that
will spawn a door the store will send
you back to your reality for a very
short amount of time if you manage to
make it to the same place where Leo was
taken into the game you will end up at
the same level as Leo when the man in
the coat brings you back into the game
to do the glitch all you need to do is
Spam the space bar when you're a bit
further out
also be cautious when you're back in
your own reality the man in the coat
might try to kill you for breaking the
rules good luck
okay
whatever you say
I'm too tough to kill things I think
some kind of oh you unknown here oh yeah
got a door sweet
easy
all right so I gotta go buy a lake
somewhere I have to go to a lake I'm
free I'm free I'm freaking out of here
you gotta be out of my car
I got my keys
maybe we'll see about that oh dude
all right I gotta go to the last
location but also the man in the coat
might kill me so you know whatever okay
oh God it's so far away huh hope the man
in the coat isn't standing ominously in
the middle of the road while I'm driving
I might want to gun it you know I might
want to you know gun it I might want to
go fast I might want to go real fast oh
God keep my why oh frick
hey I remember that nighttime radio
spikes
that's a big
I don't know why they expected me to be
driving in the center of the road I
follow the rules
except when I pop a curb like that kind
of peaceful actually that was kind of a
nice drive a little break in the action
Arc
well time to be taken back into the game
for all the good that it will do
hey a picnic you think no one picked
this up
I'm gonna play the game
hello
oh
oh oh wow
interesting so what benefit is this
going to have
I don't understand
[Music]
oh player two joined level oh I don't
like that all right it's me player two I
don't know where I am but uh player two
is here
ready and willing oh never mind please
don't I'm not willing I'm unwilling
I'm so unwilling
don't do it I'll blink oh don't do it
I'm unblinked I want to open my eyes
okay fine it's fine panicking over
nothing
why am I what happened to me well some
big bubble own baby over here
a big strong I can't move
oh that is not good
Leo
please help me Evan
goodbye
I don't know what that was about oh all
right I don't know how to help you I
really don't you've seen a door around
here somewhere
that was kind of the deal that was told
about before that there would be some
kind of a door
oh boy
oh the man in the code
the man to the coat the throat goat
himself
holy crap
[Applause]
holy crap an unknown force is holding
him back is it
God give me a gun
this is the kind of game that I could
get behind
save the corrupted souls to save Thomas
okay
you got it save the four souls I did it
level 32 find Barney oh I have to find
okay I gotta get them all individually
they're all still in here almost
oh God it's amazing I'm never gonna get
out of here oh frick I'm never going to
unless this path on the ground shows me
whatever I need to go that'd be nice
[Music]
so far so good awfully nice when they
give me a hint like this unless it's
leading me into my Doom which I would be
the most gullible person in the world if
this was a trap or I'd be so smart
because no one else would see this ah no
this is too obvious this is a trap I'm
gonna die I'm not gonna die I'm gonna
live
I'm dead I'm Not Dead
shockingly I hear ominous noise I'm dead
I'm alive
I'm dying we're all dying but I'm not
alive hi I found you I'm alive you're
alive we're live come with me
why should I even try to progress
anymore
I'm just gonna end up dead in another
level I can help you if you help me and
it sounds like people going through the
five stages of grief when they play
Elden ring or something like that or any
dark Phil's game I don't need any
freaking help I'm fine with staying here
I can get you home
can I
fly home yes I just need you to trust me
random stranger do you trust me complete
unknown person
if you trust me good I trust you why
I have no idea why why would you
oh good
oh dementia Oh weird
help Carlos bull okay
I feel lost
okay uh
vinyl
and
oh I remember this oh
I used to listen to this tune all the
time baby
the kids always used to beg me to turn
down the volume and me and the guys used
to play cards while listening to this
[Music]
yeah
well that was an easy soul to save
those memories were my soul
oh well all right well this is gonna be
that easy all you gotta do is pick up a
vinyl listen to some tunes play some
cons
ENT depression oh
cool
Davey Davey Baby Dave
Dave Dave Dave
Dave Dave Greg Bill Steve Dave Dave I
knew it was you how's the wife
Dave
leave me alone
Dave hey man is everything all right
random stranger
no what's wrong I just feel so empty I
hate the feeling and I can't even
explain why I'm feeling it Hey listen
there will always be moments in life
where you feel as if nothing matters the
feeling that you'll never feel better
again and an urge to give up on
everything
I promise you
it gets better in the end please don't
isolate yourself I'm here for you if
you'd like to talk
I didn't even realize I was I could see
anything oh no I couldn't see anything
I'd like that actually hello
you're not alone
I'm I'm like a hero
I don't even know these people but
I'm a Hero level error grandson's safe
Zone
that's strange it once again seems like
I'm in the woods from the beginning of
the game
so
hi hello if it's just a matter of hey
come with me then that makes it a lot
easier
so uh come with me
hello
have I been forgotten Evan
did anyone even remember me after I
Disappeared
you haven't even been forgotten at all
I miss you so much Leo and so is
everyone else
and your mom
Evan
I want to go home
well if it was that easy
feel like I should have fortified oh
right four or five right Tom Thomas
Tommy
hey Tom oh God don't do it don't what
are you doing okay got that one
what do I do I've got a soul in my hand
a soul in my pocket what do I do I do
not know soul of Leo Williams got it oh
interesting ah
don't shoot your big Soul cannon at me
don't you do it
yeah maybe these people aren't maybe I
shouldn't save these people they kind of
look a little
take some of that
take some of the [ __ ] you didn't like
that
I'm saving him by destroying him
that way his soul can never haunt us
ever again
and we'll be free oh hi hello
thank you Evan
you have not only saved me but you have
saved us all
[Music]
I can now send all of you back to your
families
aren't you coming with us I'm fine with
staying here you have already killed the
entity so by staying here I can live in
peace here I can be truly happy
[Music]
but now I think it's
to return home
thank you heaven
[Music]
door I'm gone later everybody I'm out of
here I'm saved I get it
I did it going home now I don't know how
long these people have been missing or
if they've aged in the game
well there you have it
I thought that was pretty good the scary
moments were like really really really
freaking scary the stair level thing
that could be an entire game by itself
but then again it kind of is with
scp-087b but still very fun very good I
feel like it kind of like got a little
slow towards the end as it like really
had to wrap up a lot of story in one go
of things but still very fun I like that
I like the ambition of it I like people
trying to reach a little higher based on
Jordan's recurring childhood nightmares
oh
but still very fun I like trying to
reach for something that's more than
just a demo or something like that more
than just like a small sample of a game
very good stuff thank you Jordan CL
thank you everybody so much for watching
look out behind you because now this
YouTube is breaking through into your
world
[Music]